[Musik]
warten testen warten bei den crooner
tests in deutschland gibt es weiter
große probleme und dabei steigt die zahl
der neuinfektionen
der druck der straße wächst in belarus
muss sich präsident lukaschenko vom
eigenen publikum anhören tritt zurück
wie geht's raus aus dem umfragetief fdp
chef lindner wechselt knapp ein jahr vor
der bundestagswahl die generalsekretärin
aus
nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers guten abend zu ihrer
nachrichtenübersicht in einer neuen
woche sport heute abend mit rudi cerne
hallo guten habt die korona infektionen
neben zu in deutschland und die frage
drängt was dagegen tun
es sind zwei große bereiche die den
verantwortlichen sorgen machen
partys und familienfeiern bei denen der
schutz am ende zu kurz kommt und die
menschen die zurückkommen aus
risikogebieten im ausland dieser trend
nach oben zeigt sich auch im
durchschnitt der gemeldeten infizierten
in den letzten sieben tagen die zahl pro
tag ist leicht gestiegen auf 1100 und wo
haben sich die menschen das virus
eingefangen zu 69 prozent in deutschland
sagt das robert koch institut in seinem
aktuellsten bericht und nennt dar an
erster stelle größere feiern im familien
und freundeskreis im ausland steckten
sich danach 31 prozent der menschen mit
dem virus an dieser anteil nimmt seit
beginn der sommerferien allerdings
stetig zu thomas konsum berichtet vom
strand in die schlange heißt es für
rückkehrer aus mallorca immer mehr
urlaubsländer sind risikogebiete
bedeutet immer mehr müssen sich testen
lassen anstehen für den abstrich haben
gut kennt auch beim hautarzt machen aber
ich will halt braucht schnell meiner
geld nicht einfach das mit dem schnellen
ergebnis die tester am limit zweieinhalb
bis 3000 test am tag an die 8000 tests
gemacht da knüpft an allen ecken und
enden
liegt übrigens nicht am sogenannten pcr
test selbst für den gibt es noch keine
alternative
nach rund drei stunden ist er fertig
hinzu kommt aber dass das ja auch
spezielle labors sein müssen und die
proben müssen dorthin geschickt werden
und ganz die ganze logistik muss
natürlich auch durchgeführt werden das
alles zusammen macht den test natürlich
relativ umständlich einfacher macht dem
chaos jetzt offenbar auch in bayern
qr-code statt drei stück notizen prinzip
registrieren testen handy das ergebnis
bekommen dass das schnell da ist wichtig
auch für schüler und lehrer
denn in drei weiteren bundesländern hat
der regelunterricht begonnen heute
morgen habe ich gleich noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass wenn jemand aus einem
risikogebiet zurück kommt dass er
hoffentlich eine negativen test carola
test dabei hat und wenn nicht möglich
sich bitte sofort bei uns melden damit
wir dann eben reagieren können und gehen
aus der schule wieder nach hause bringen
können
ein appell ehrlich zu sein überprüfen
schwierig deshalb setzten auch schulen
vor allem auf das was in der korona
krise überhaupt wichtig ist vertrauen
kurzarbeit soll jobs in der korona krise
retten und deshalb wird die maximale
bezugsdauer für das kurzarbeitergeld
wohl verlängert von einem auf zwei jahre
das hatte bereits finanzminister olaf
scholz vorgeschlagen und heute äußerte
sich auch kanzlerin angela merkel dazu
positiv beschlossen wird die
verlängerung voraussichtlich ende des
monats im koalitionsausschuss und um
familien in der korona zeit zu helfen
hatte die regierung einen kinderbonus
versprochen 300 euro pro kind ab dem
siebten september soll das geld jetzt
ausgezahlt werden und zwar in zwei
teilbeträgen bis oktober den bonus
erhält wer ein anrecht auf kindergeld
hat
familien mit höheren einkommen
profitieren nicht weil bei ihnen der
bonus mit dem kinderfreibetrag
verrechnet wird
kroner zahlen die steigen sorgen die
wachsen dazu gibt es ein zdf spezial
gleich nach uns hier im zdf und alle
infos zur virus krise gebündelt
jederzeit online in unserer zdf heute
app so viel zunächst zum thema
die belarussische hauptstadt minsk ist
von berlin genauso weit entfernt wie
etwa paris was in belarus passiert
sollte uns also interessieren
der widerstand gegen den
langzeit-präsidenten in belarus wird
jeden tag größer
unterstützung bekommen die demonstranten
aus deutschland
ich ablehne die bedenken wegen des
gesprächs stehen nicht auf gewalt
versetzen sondern auch den dialog dialog
veränderung davon wollte alexander
lukaschenko bislang nichts wissen
seine machtbasis aber scheint kleiner zu
werden wie vor berichtet 26 jahre an der
spitze eines autoritären staates
da kommen wieder worte für alexander
lukaschenko ganz offensichtlich
überraschend und dann noch in dieser
lautstärke
ein tribunal fordern die mitarbeiter
dieses traktorenwerk dorthin war der
präsident geflogen um sich treue zu
sichern zu lassen jetzt
fassungslosigkeit
genauso wie ihr so verstehe ich nicht wo
gerade das problem ist
v abrufen die arbeiter und luca
schenkung geht dank kürzlich habe alles
gesagt jetzt könnt ihr how abrufen
neuwahlen lehnt lukaschenko erste strikt
ab dann stellte sie noch einem
referendum in aussicht während also
unklar bleibt was der präsident will ist
ihr wunsch eindeutig mehr demokratie
dafür liegen tausende fabrikarbeiter
bisher verlässlicher rückhalt für
lukaschenko die arbeit nieder
auch ein zweiter pfeiler bilder
russischer macht wird bestreikt leeres
studio am morgen im staatlich
kontrollierten fernsehen das war zuletzt
dadurch aufgefallen dass über die
oppositionsbewegung nicht oder nicht
objektiv berichtet wurde
ich nehme heute nicht nur an dem streik
teil ich werde auch meine kündigung
einreichen
die zeit ist gekommen in der wir
journalisten gerade wir eine
entscheidung treffen müssen
ich habe gesehen dass man manchmal das
ein oder andere thema nicht anfassen
darf oder etwas korrigieren muss oder
informationen vertreten bis sie nicht
mehr der realität entsprechen aus dem
exil meldet sich svetlana tarnowski die
oppositionsführerin bekräftigt
verantwortung übernehmen zu wollen
damit belarus zur ruhe komme und noch
zwei fragen dazu an unsere komponente
den moskauer firma guten abend auf wie
viel rückhalt kann sich präsident
lukaschenko dennoch verlassen in belarus
also dass sein rückhalt in der
bevölkerung schwindet das können wir von
tag zu tag beobachten die proteste den
schließen sich wirklich belarussen aus
allen gesellschaftsschichten an
aber ein anderes thema das ist der
machtzirkel von lukaschenko selbst also
die hochrangigen beamten die
polizeichefs und auch die hochrangigen
militärs von denen hat bisher noch
niemand öffentlich lukaschenko den
rücken gekehrt und sollte das passieren
sollten da risse offenkundig werden dann
würde es wirklich eng werden für
alexander lukaschenko und dann sollten
wir noch kurz auf die russische sicht
gucken wie ernst ist denn die russische
ankündigung zu nehmen man werde dem
staatschef in belarus notfalls helfen
ganz klar ist dass es für den kreml auf
keinen fall attraktiv sein kann
lukaschenko hier in einer
in einer protestbewegung untergehen zu
sehen und zwar aus zwei gründen erstens
würde das der opposition hier in
russland aufschwung geben
die würde zu neuer kraft finden
womöglich und dann dem kreml unbequem
werden und zweitens müsste der kreml
nicht wer auf lukaschenko folgen würde
und ob diese personen die dann den
präsidentensessel übernimmt auch so ein
treuer verbündeter oder eine treue
verbündete für moskau wäre
eines scheint aus derzeitiger sicht
relativ offensichtlich oder relativ klar
zumindest dass ein militärisches
einschreiten für vor aus russland in
belarus auch für den kreml eine eher
unattraktive lösung wäre hintergründe
aus moskau von firma garbe vielen dank
dafür
der dauer krisenherd libyen ist von
frieden weiter weit entfernt
bundesaußenminister heiko maas warnte
heute in tripolis davor dass die kämpfe
wieder aufflammen
als herrsche derzeit eine trügerische
ruhe sieben monate nach den berliner
libyen gipfel wird der dort vereinbarte
stopp von waffenlieferungen in das land
noch immer nicht eingehalten
in die bundespolitik stühlerücken in der
fdp spitze der parteichef christian
lindner löst seine generalsekretärin
vorzeitig ab auf linda teuteberg soll
der landesparteichef aus rheinland-pfalz
volker wissing folgen
er ist auch wirtschaftsminister in mainz
lindner übte indirekt kritik an der
bisherigen generalsekretärin und
kündigte an die fdp in sachen
wirtschaftspolitik besser aufstellen zu
wollen frank buchwald berichtet
umfragewerte knapp über fünf prozent die
fdp in der opposition kaum sichtbar
nun wagt parteichef lindner einen
befreiungsschlag präsentiert einen neuen
generalsekretär volker wissing die lage
im land hat sich verändert wie ich sagte
also ändern wir auch unsere aufstellung
unserer thematisches profil das auch
natürlich durch persönlichkeiten die in
spitzenfunktionen sind repräsentiert
wird noch generalsekretär in linda
teuteberg erst letztes jahr gewählt gibt
ihr amt nach zähem ringen auf als
fachpolitikerin respektiert viele aber
kritisierten unter der hand sie greife
politische gegner nicht scharf genug an
ich sags ganz offen in der führung der
partei brauche ich in dieser lage mehr
hilfe und unterstützung
und deshalb bin ich dankbar dass volker
wissing in die bundespolitik
zurückkehren
nun soll es also richten finanzfachmann
wirtschaftsminister architekt eine
ampelkoalition was denn nun vorhat
klingt ungewohnt
mir ist es wichtig dass die
themensetzung nicht nur von der
politischen klasse kommt sondern dass
wir wirklich nah dass ohren den menschen
haben um die themen aufzugreifen die sie
umtreiben unter gehören für mich auch
beispielsweise ernährungsfragen dazu die
frage wie gehen wir mit ethischen fragen
in der tierhaltung um themen die bei der
fdp so bisher nicht im mittelpunkt
standen
reden wir noch im moment über den fdp
chef christian lindner theologen nach
berlin ist das heute ein zeichen für
lindners stärke oder von schwäche ich
glaube es ist ein zeichen dass sich ein
geschwächter hilfe holt lindner hat die
fdp ja bedrohlich nah an die fünf
prozent hürde geführt und damit an den
rand der politischen todeszone der neue
generalsekretär gilt als angriff stärker
und er soll als finanzfachmann die fdp
und damit ja auch lindner in den
absehbar bevorstehenden kroner
wirtschaftskrisen und dem kommenden
superwahljahr stärken das ganze
beinhaltet aber nebenbei auch ein
strategisches signal der neue
generalsekretär ist ja im hauptberuf
mächtiger minister in der ampel
koalition in rheinland pfalz und dort
wird im frühjahr gewählt sollte die
ampel also die regierung aus spd grünen
und fdp dort bei den landtagswahlen gut
abschneiden dann könnte das für
christian lindner auch eine art
bewerbungsschreiben richtung olaf scholz
sein denn dem wird ja mehr sympathie für
die ampel als für ein linksbündnis
nachgesagt die strategien in berlin
herzlichen dank für diese erläuterung es
gibt verbrechen die ungleich mehr
verstören als andere
der missbrauchsfall von bergisch
gladbach gehört dazu vor dem kölner
landgericht muss sich von heute an ein
mann verantworten der seine tochter
dutzendfach missbraucht haben soll
seit sie drei monate alt war seine taten
soll er gefilmt und weiterverbreitet
haben seine festnahme löste ermittlungen
gegen viele andere männer aus vom
prozess berichtet dort ferber äußerlich
ungerührt hört der beschuldigte j l die
anklage wie seine kleine tochter beim
missbrauch bauer nein und wenn es nach
der mutter gerufen habe aol soll das
mädchen seit ihrem dritten lebensmonat
vergewaltigt haben
bilder davon soll er ins netz gestellt
mit gleichgesinnten männern geteilt
haben
das besondere an diesem fall ist das
brutale vorgehen was wir bei den tätern
feststellen mussten wir haben sich
kinder getauscht gegenseitig zugeführt
und auch bei der bei dem
missbrauchshandlungen ist man äußerst
brutal vorgegangen
ein riesiger missbrauchs komplex die
ermittlergruppe wurde nachdem in
bergisch gladbach wohnenden angeklagten
jörg l benannt die hausdurchsuchung bei
ihm brachte die polizei auf das
bundesweite netzwerk mit riesigen
datenmengen
inzwischen gibt es 30.000 digitale
spuren zu verdächtigen
bei der identifizierung von chat
partnern soll jörg l geholfen haben
die haben über messenger dienste
verschiedener art kommuniziert und zum
teil auch sehr freizügig kommuniziert
ohne sich großartig zu verstecken
sondern auch oft eine sehr direkte
sprache gewählt was uns natürlich jetzt
auch in der beweisführung einiges
erleichtert eine stunde dauert die
anklageverlesung gegen j l
dann sagt der gelernte koch und
hotelfachmann aus unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit
ihm drohen bis zu 15 jahre
freiheitsstrafe und sicherungsverwahrung
mit einem urteil wird ende september
gerechnet
bilder von einem polizeieinsatz in
düsseldorf sorgen für empörung auch er
habe sich erschrocken sagt
nordrhein-westfalens innenminister
herbert reul und kündigt an dass
umfassend aufzuklären
das video von samstag zeigt die zwei
polizeibeamte einen 15 jährigen am boden
festhalten
einer der beiden trug dabei sein knie
auf den kopf des jugendlichen
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt
wegen des verdachts auf körperverletzung
im amt
der jugendliche soll die polizisten
zuvor angegriffen haben
anderes thema das hat aber auch mit der
polizei in nrw zu tun und deren kampf
gegen kriminalität die dort so
verbreitet ist wie in keinem anderen
bundesland
laut ermittlern gibt es 111 clans
großfamilien mit türkischem und
arabischem hintergrund das bka definiert
kleinkriminalität als eigene form des
organisierten verbrechens drogenhandel
illegales glücksspiel raub
körperverletzung die liste ist lang
thaddäus parade jetzt mit der bilanz aus
düsseldorf groß razzia im ruhrgebiet es
sind polizei aktionen wie die vom
vergangenen wochenende mit denen der
nordrhein westfälische innenminister
herbert reul kriminellen clans das
wasser abgraben will politik der 10.000
nadelstiche nennt er das wir machen vor
allen dingen klar das ist das wichtigste
bei uns gilt das gesetz der familie
nicht sondern das gesetz des staates
türkisch arabischen großfamilien mit
zweifelhaftem ehrenkodex dazu methoden
wie bei der mafia
all das erschwert die arbeit der polizei
enorm doch erste erfolge sind messbar
gegenüber dem bundesweit erst ein klares
lagebild aus dem vorjahr stieg die zahl
der ermittelten straftaten um 12,7
prozent der verdächtigen mit klaren
hintergrund um 13,4 prozent
kern müssen wir feststellen dass wir
eine zunahme von straftaten im bereich
glenz haben die wir auch und ganz
wesentlich darauf zurückzuführen dass
die kontrollintensität der
verfolgungsdruck der polizei nordrhein
westfalen deutlich größer geworden ist
bei den straftaten dominieren
rohheitsdelikte gefolgt von betrugs- und
eigentumsdelikten
kleinkriminalität findet vor allem in
größeren städten statt das ruhrgebiet
bildet dabei nach wie vor den
schwerpunkt großrazzien und mehr
kontrollen im kampf gegen kriminalität
sei das nicht genug sagen kritiker wenn
sie das darin spiegeln dass die
landesregierung in ihrer personal
verteilung ganze 20 stellen für
nordrhein westfalen für die
kriminalpolizei zur bekämpfung der
kleinkriminalität vorgesehen hat dann
können sie vielleicht erahnen an welcher
stelle unsere kritik an setzt trotz
erster erfolge wird deutlich kriminelle
clanstrukturen zu bekämpfen erfordert
einen langen atem
beim absturz eines heißluftballons in
rheinland pfalz ist der ballonführer ums
leben gekommen zwei weitere menschen
wurden schwer verletzt
das unglück ereignete sich nahe des
berühmten loreley-felsen felsens im
oberen mittelrheintal
offenbar wurde der ballon gestern abend
im landeanflug von einem windstoß
erfasst dadurch schlug der korb mit
seinen sieben passagieren mehrfach auf
einen acker und rutschte einen hang
hinab die bahnstrecke koblenz mainz
sowie eine bundesstraße waren
vorübergehend gesperrt und unwetter mit
sehr viel regen habe in einigen regionen
von deutschland für keller voller wasser
und verkehrschaos gesorgt besonders
betroffenen nordrhein-westfalen
nachbarschaftshilfe hier in dortmund um
autos aus den fluten zu retten diese
senke ist vollgelaufen wohnungen stehen
unter wasser
land unter auch hier im kreis neuss der
starke regen hat zahlreiche keller
überschwemmt feuerwehr und anwohner im
großeinsatz
und alle wetter details gleich in der
sendung aber erst der sport mit rolli
der woche der entscheidung im fußball
morgen abend steht für rb leipzig das
größte spiel in der ersten elf jahre
alten vereins geschichte an
champions-league-halbfinale gegen paris
st germain in lissabon
dabei geht es für rb auch um mehr
anerkennung in deutschland hier am
strand von echter rill durften leipzigs
profis gestern ein wenig die seele
baumeln lassen nach ihrem begeisternden
sieg gegen atletico madrid
eine image erfolg auch gegen breite
ablehnung in deutschland so verweigert
etwa ein angesehenes fußball
kulturmagazin noch immer jegliche
berichterstattung über rb weil der klub
allein zum zwecke des kommerzes
gegründet worden sein
wir sind elf freunde auf dem platz das
hat man gesehen und das werden wir auch
morgen abend seien und ob dann das ein
oder andere magazin darüber berichtet
oder nicht spielt für uns keine große
rolle
dennoch ein jubelfest gegen das
star-ensemble aus paris wäre ein
weiterer schritt zu mehr anerkennung den
mächtigen fußabdruck eines champions
league finalisten könnte wohl keiner
mehr ignorieren und für den fall dass
sich mindestens eine deutsche mannschaft
für das finale am kommenden sonntag
qualifiziert überträgt das zdf die
begegnung live mittwochabend bestreitet
bayern münchen ja noch das zweite
halbfinale gegen olympique lyon und in
der europa league steht der erste
finalteilnehmer fest der fc sevilla
besiegt in köln manchester united mit 2
zu 1 und träumt jetzt vom sechsten titel
gewinnen ein bitterer abend hingegen für
manunited
ein enttäuschter ole gunnar solskjaer
nach schlusspfiff seine red devils trotz
zahlreicher chancen im halbfinale
ausgeschieden
wenn du diese gelegenheiten nutzt
gewinnst du locker aber so ist das eben
manchmal im fußball
nach einem foul von diego carlos an
rasch vor ort im strafraum hatte bruno
fernandes manchester zunächst per
elfmeter in führung gebracht
in einer packenden partie gelangen
stürmer suso aber der ausgleich für
sevilla
in der zweiten hälfte dann ein pass von
kapitän ressourcen abbas aus dem nichts
auf joker luuk de jong der ex-gladbacher
als matchwinner
in der 78 minute im finale der europa
league wird der fc sevilla auf den
sieger der partie heute zwischen inter
mailand und schachtar donezk treffen und
das war's vom sport christian bakkerud
wir können jetzt alle gemeinsam uns noch
auf ein jubiläum der popgeschichte
gucken dass sie jetzt in hamburg feiern
vor genau 60 jahren kommen hier ein paar
jungs aus liverpool an
im club indra haben sie ihren ersten
auftritt in deutschland und dann jeden
abend auf die bühne
es spricht sich herum sie nennen sich
die beatles in hamburg wurden wir
erwachsen sagte john lennon
der rest ist bekannt durchatmen beim
wetter nach hitze und schwüle bringen
die gewitter frischere luft alle details
gleich von katja honnefer um 21 uhr 45
ist die kollegin marietta slomka für sie
da und es gibt es morgen wieder danke
für ihr interesse jetzt gleich zdf
spezial und in allen einen angenehmen
abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren die
unwetter der letzten drei tage haben den
regen ganz ungleichmäßig verteilt im
thüringer wald gab es bis zu 100 liter
regen pro quadratmeter in anderen
regionen fiel gar nicht das aber wird
sich jetzt ändern mit einem tief
westlich von nutzt das ist das tief
ingrid und das schaufel sie ja auch
heute kräftige regenschauer und gewitter
heran und es schleudert sie auch in der
nacht und morgen über tag über
mitteleuropa
dann allerdings wird die schwüle hitze
aus ostdeutschland langsam vertrieben
heute nacht gewitters noch zwischen nord
fließen und und niederbayern hinter den
gewittern lockern die wolken auf und es
entwickelt sich auch mal nebel
das wird eine angenehm frische nacht im
westen mit tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
15 und 11 grad im nordosten bleibt es
dagegen noch sehr laube 8 10 bis 16 grad
am morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
der deutschlandweit zwischen 21 grad am
alpenrand und 26 grad am main oder an
der elbe und im nordosten kann es zum
teil kräftige gewitter geben also welche
die mit hagel platzregen und sturmböen
verbunden sind
im bestens ist erstmal sehr freundlich
nachmittags allerdings können sich dann
dort auch wieder einige regenschauer und
gewitter entwickeln
am mittwoch gibt es dann höchstens noch
in vorpommern einige gewitter danach
geht es deutlich heißer weiter schönen
abend noch